Emmanuel coachia nous traversons une
crise majeure qui a de multiples
facettes mais qui est avant tout une
crise climatique quel rôle le philosophe
peut-il jouer là-dedans
mais la philosophie un rôle majeur parce
que si on peut résoudre ces
soucis cette crise c'est parce que on
est arrivé à aimer les mondes ce monde
la Terre la planète de manière
obsessionnelle jusqu'à vouloir en sauver
la moindre particule mais est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il y a une philosophie de
la crise qui serait spécifique au moment
que nous vivons est-ce que la crise
contraint en quelque sorte convoque un
nouveau type de philosophie je sais pas
s'il y a un philosophie de la crise
ce qui est sûr c'est que on a vécu et
pas juste à cause de la crise climatique
un moment disons un démi siècle de
transformation radicale comme peut-être
à peine l'humanité un tiers à un
traversé au sens que il y a une
révolution technologique qui a été
incroyable moi je fais partie de
personnes qui qui ont vécu la transition
entre les moments où il fallait aller en
bi avec pour chercher de savoir et les
moments où la totalité de savoir est
dans ta poche littéralement dans ta
poche il est ultra formation
géopolitique monstrueuse en fait qui
fait que voilà
l'axe du pouvoir sur la planète comme un
se déplacer en Asie et il y a eu ces
changements climatiques majeur et c'est
ensemble de changements fait que au fond
c'est comme si on habitait pas la même
planète de nos parents c'est comme si
l'humanité entière avait été déplacée
sur notre planète et donc c'est comme si
chacune et chacun de nous étaient un peu
dans la même position de Adam et Eve qui
sont obligés à nommer les choses qu'il
voit pour la première fois
et c'est une posture à la fois
etivrante parce que nommer les choses
découvert les choses posées soit la
réalité le tout premier regard c'est
quelque chose de sublime mais aussi
dangereux parce qu'on n'est pas donc on
risque chaque instant de ce brûler la
peau de se faire mal de mourir etc donc
il n'y a pas peut-être une philosophie
de la crise mais c'est sûr que le notre
situation est incomparable et c'est sûr
que on est appelé à réimaginer
réconfigurer à produire des nouveaux
savoirs sur sur les mondes en fait alors
je vais réagir à propos de Michel
Foucault qui justement définit la
philosophie en disant peut-être que il y
en a plus on va l'écouter en 1966 il est
très difficile au fond de définir ce
qu'est actuellement la philosophie il me
semble que maintenant la philosophie est
en train de disparaître quand je dis
qu'elle disparaît je ne veux pas dire
que nous arrivons à un âge où finalement
tout le savoir devient positif mais je
crois que la philosophie se dissout et
se dissipe dans toute une série
d'activités de pensées dont il est
difficile de dire si elles sont
proprement scientifiques ou proprement
philosophiques nous arrivons à un âge
qui est peut-être celui de la pensée
pure de la pensée en acte et après tout
une discipline aussi abstraite et
générale que la linguistique une
discipline aussi fondamentale que la
logique une activité comme la
littérature depuis Joyce par exemple et
bien toutes ces activités sont
probablement des activités de pensée
et elles tiennent lieu de philosophie
n'ont pas qu'elles prennent la place de
la philosophie mais en quelque sorte
elles sont le déploiement même de ce qui
était autrefois la philosophie
pas mal à ce qu'on entendait à la
télévision en 66
de radicaliser son propre au sens que
font la philosophie a toujours été
dissipée dissolu
je répète vent si on s’épend sur les
canons de la philosophie qu'on a censé
enseigner par exemple aux élèves
au lycée ou à la fac
Foucault parlait déjà mais Platon a
produit des œuvres techniquement
littéraires Le Crès a écrit un poème
qu'on étudie aussi dans les études de
littérature
etc etc au fond la littérature n'a
jamais été une discipline spécifique
même pas au Moyen-Âge font la
philosophie était comme un dissociable
de la théologie qui est une science très
bizarre et très différente et ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est peut-être que on
trouve de la pensée philosophique un peu
comme disait Foucault un peu partout
surtout par exemple à lézard on a fait
des lards une discipline de la pensée ou
chaque artiste doit tout d'abord
réinventer les médiums nécessaires pour
exprimer une idée donc d'une certaine
manière là quand elle parlait est
devenue une sorte de forme
paradigmatique de la pensée où on est
obligé tout d'abord à s'interroger sur
les conditions de possibilités
d'expression d'une idée
qui est très importante parce que la
prise de conscience qui a lieu
aujourd'hui c'est que on n'est pas
obligé à écrire pour penser pour faire
de la philosophie donc la philosophie se
fait plus vraiment à l'université mais
dans des nouvelles pratiques dans des
pratiques de création alors la
philosophie s'est fait très rarement à
l'université en fait dans les sens que
si on regarde qui ont fait l'histoire ça
s'est passé que dans des moments très
spécifiques un peu Moyen-âge et même
parce que c'était pas dans les facs de
philosophie c'était plus surtout d'aller
faire des théologies et un peu à l'âge
moderne mais pourronter courberré dans
l'histoire de ce qu'on appelle
philosophie la pensée c'est que c'est un
peu partout même un marchand même je
sais pas faisons la vaisselle donc
l'université ce n'est pas les lieux un
plus par définition qui doit produire de
la philosophie c'est les lieux qui est
censé à la limite la transmettre
l'université le lieu où on s'épance sur
ce qu'il s'est passé il y a un
demi-siècle ou bien il y a plusieurs
siècles et puis ou de l'histoire de
n'importe quoi alors que par exemple il
y a une inversion intéressante les
musées qui étaient une institution
tournée vers les passés et devenu un
laboratoire de divination du futur à tel
point qu'on va voir une expo d'Arc en
tempérance justement aussi et surtout
pour deviner les futurs plutôt que pour
comprendre les présents ou les passer il
faut si on veut vraiment retransformer à
nouveau ou faire des universités à lieu
de de laboration du futur il faut leur
donner cette liberté de brasser
n'importe quel aspect de la de
l'existence humaine et pas que humaine
d'ailleurs et de d'utiliser n'importe
quel médium j'aurais du mal à dire
ce que c'est la philosophie dans les
sciences que font si on sait penche sur
l'ensemble de livres ou de personnes
connaissances et considérées comme des
philosophes
mais cet ensemble réunit des gens des
livres des sujets totalement disparate
qui n'ont pas qui n'ont aucune unité
dans la méthode de l'objet d'halestine
il y a des livres qui ressemblent à des
œuvres littéraires il a du Luc qui
ressemble à des œufs à 2 œuvres à des
traiter d'économie il y a des poèmes il
y a des tags en fait qui sont des
oeuvres philosophiques et au fond la
seule manière de de finir la philosophie
c'est de revenir
aux deux concepts contenus d'insolents
qui selon grec qui est l'amour et les
savoirs donc au fond les philosophes ce
sont des
aimants de amateurs de de force de la
connaissance mais qui sont alimentés
nourrit que par cette patience aveugle
et obsessionnel en fait
ce qui veut dire font pour le traduire
que la philosophie est partout n'est pas
un savoir parmi les autres mais c'est
une intensité qui traverse n'importe
quel savoir n'importe quel discipline
alors vous pratiquez ce genre de
philosophie c'est même assez hybride vos
essais ils sont à la fois poétiques
philosophiques est-ce que c'est parce
que vous avez finalement une formation
tout à fait singulière et différente par
rapport à un professeur de philosophie
puisque vous avez commencé finalement
vos études dans un lycée agricole
j'étais envoyé oui dans une lycée dans
un lycée agricole par un geste féminisme
inconscient de ma mère qui a envoyé ma
sœur est née au lycée classique donc là
où on apprend les Grecs les latents et
moi mon frère ma mère nous a dit il faut
apprendre un métier en fait donc
c'était une stratégie efficace parce que
justement pour démontrer à ma mère que
je pouvais faire
université je suis devenu même prof à la
fac je me suis retrouvé dans cette dans
cet endroit qui était à l'époque un
endroit d'exclusion de toute forme de
mentalité ou de ou de société mais qui
m'a qui m'a fait énormément du bien
pour deux raisons tout d'abord parce que
au fond les entendus étaient que les
premiers objets du savoir ou de l'effort
de connaissance se sont les plantes et
donc les monuments les mondes lui-même
et pas l'humain donc elle m'a appris à
comprendre que si on doit
se forcer du produire de la connaissance
c'est parce que les mondes est plus
importants que nous-mêmes et après parce
que ce lycée m'a mis dans une posture ou
d'un position de à la fois outsider et
des philosophes c'est à dire au fond
j'étais obligé à apprendre tout ce que
je voulais apprendre par une volonté par
une passion personnelle et pas par et
pas forcément en passant par un maître
par une école par une discipline par une
méthode etc ça a donné un très beau
livre qui s'intitule la vie des plantes
qui est peut-être celui qui vous a fait
connaître du grand public et dans lequel
effectivement alors vous travaillez sur
le rôle absolument fondamental de la
plante qui crée le monde en quelque
sorte qui fait monde vous privilégiez
finalement la vie sensible à la vie
intelligible est-ce qu'on peut revenir
un petit peu sur cette vie des plantes
et questions subsidiaire en quoi de ce
fait le philosophe a quelque chose de
plus à dire que par exemple le botaniste
le chercheur en sciences de la nature
parce que j'ai essayé de faire dans ces
livres c'est tirer les derniers
dernières conséquences de ce que on peut
trouver dans n'importe quel manuel du
Botanic c'est-à-dire font l'une des
premières phrases qu'on trouvera dans la
porte botanique n'apporte à niveau c'est
que
les plantes grassent à la photosynthèse
modifie le
la teneur à un oxygène et l'atmosphère
donc modifie l'atmosphère terrestre
planétaire et
modifie évidemment le les sols etc mais
modifie aussi la présence de l'énergie
sur Terre en fait donc première
conséquence qu'on peut durer de ce fait
élémentaire c'est que
les monts tel qu'on les connaît a été
produit littéralement produit par les
plantes en fait donc qui permettent à la
terre de devenir un espace respirable et
qui surtout mettent à disposition les
animaux quantité inouïe d'énergie au
fond les plantes capture l'énergie
solaire qui a d'ailleurs on l'oublie
mais l'énergie solaire c'est comme cette
un élément extraterrestre ce qui fait
que notre vie ou que nous sommes
nous-mêmes et les plantes d'ailleurs
elles-mêmes un peu des aliens des
extraterrestres en fait de à moitié on a
un squelette terrestre et une vie qui
est alimentée par une source d'énergie
extraterrestre et d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce qu'il capture
l'énergie solaire il a il a comme il a
un souffle de la chair minérale de la
planète ce qui fait qu'au fond à chaque
fois ça sonne un peu bizarre mais à
chaque fois qu'on mange on est en train
de chercher cette énergie qui est cachée
dans les quarts des autres
ce qui fait de la nutrition
au fond cette quête presque spirituelle
des lumières et cette ce commerce de
lumière qui passe de corps de Space en
espèces mais la deuxième conséquence est
encore plus intéressantes au fond les
plantes nous enseignent deux choses tout
d'abord que les mondes est un espace
fabriqué et pas naturel en fait la Terre
a été rendue habitable vivable par les
vivants eux-mêmes qu'ils ont scicelé
depuis des milliards d'années qu'il en
transformé donc la terre au fond c'est
un artefact qui est pas moins artificiel
que notre smartphone il est au fond
beaucoup plus artificiel parce qu'elle
est a été produite par des milliards de
générations de milliards des vivants
dans c'est comme si c'était une énorme
œuvre collective et d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça qu'il est si vous vulnérable et
si fragile parce que il a été produite
par plein plein des gens la deuxième
conséquence qu'on peut tirer de ce film
alimentaire de la photos parenthèse
c'est que au fond ce n'est pas vrai
qu'un vivant s'adapte à l'environnement
les vivants est obligé pour vivre de
modifier radicalement l'espace qu'il
entoure les autres vivants qui sont à
côté de lui etc etc l'environnement
c'est pas quelque chose qui est là et
auquel on doit se plier n'importe quel
vivant transforme de manière extrêmement
imprévisible et créatif
l'espace qui l'entoure c'est-à-dire la
terre en fait je crois que vous récusez
d'ailleurs le terme d'écologie
précisément j'ai les récuses parce que
c'est un terme qui a été introduit par
au fond par les comment dire les termes
écologiques étaient inventés par un
biologiste allemand du 19e siècle
on sait qu'elle mais qui modifiait un
nom qui était à l'origine celui de
économie animale c'est une science qui
surgit parce qu'on s'est rendu compte
que pour qu'on prend la relation entre
un kangao et moustique il faut des
concepts qui sont de nature sociologique
manquez pas de nature chimique
biologique physique ou quoi d'autre les
problèmes c'est que à cette époque là
comme on était encore dans sa contexte
fixiste c'est-à-dire un contexte où on
croyait que les espèces étaient les
mêmes depuis le régime du monde jusqu'à
à la fin et donc si on se penchait sur
la question quelle est les rapports
entre un kangourou assigné mystique à
Paris et un cheval un Arizona comme
c'était des trois êtres qui n'avaient
aucun rapport parenté et qui se
rencontrait pas dans leur vie donc la
seule manière de se poser de comprendre
quelle est leur relation c'était de se
mettre du point de vue de celui qui les
avait créé c'est à dire les dieux
chrétiens or les problèmes ce que si tu
observes la terre c'est à dire
l'ensemble des espaces et l'ensemble des
êtres du point de vue du dieu ce
spectacle elle va se présenter à toi
exactement comme une grande maison se
présente
exemple et empêche encore aujourd'hui
l'écologie des pensées qui les rapports
entre les êtres puissent être d'ordre
politique et pas domestique en fait
qu'il y ait une forme de la même forme
de liberté qu'il y a entre les humains
lorsqu'il sort de leur maison en fait
c'est la même capacité de être non pas
des transgresser un ordre mais d'être
totalement indifférent à l'ordre alors
qu'il règne dans nos maisons
que par exemple c'est indifférence à
l'ordre dont on fait l'expérience à
chaque fois qu'on sort en fait
c'est-à-dire au fond on a plus du
programme on est libre on peut
ce qu'on dit à ce consacrer au plaisir
les plus décennies etc dans c'est pour
ça que l'écologie doit peut-être revenir
sur son histoire
et serait répanché la source de cette
unité la raison pour laquelle tous les
êtres sont reliés les uns aux autres
à travers une image un concept une
métaphore qui n'est pas celle de la
maison on est précise que vous avez
écrit un livre sur la maison une
philosophie de la maison ou vous
remettez en cause cette dichotomie entre
intérieure et extérieure en permanence
ce qui est d'une certaine manière
logique parce que vous êtes aussi le
philosophe de la métamorphose tout est
dans tout se transforme en permanence
autre expérience
fondatrice dans votre rapport au monde
c'est celle de la gemilité vous arrivez
à une phrase tout à fait paradoxale qui
est l'idée que la gemilité est
finalement ce qu'il y a peut-être de
plus universel au monde alors que de
prime abord ou de façon intuitive plutôt
l'impression que c'est extrêmement
singulier plutôt exceptionnel comment
vous pouvez transformer ce qui
semblerait exceptionnel en quelque chose
au contraire d'universel
donc l'expérience de la gemmélité est
quelque chose de très curieux qui est
cette moi j'en ai comme un dire j'ai
compris ce que ça veut dire je me Gémo
pardon face à une image qui trône un peu
chez un appartement de ma mère ou il y a
plein plein d'images de moi et mon frère
lorsque on était tout jeune tout petit
et les images de cette âge là sont pour
moi très difficile parce que j'arrive
pas à comprendre qui est qui et c'est un
trouble de bon là de de l'acte des
reconnaissances de soi mais c'est un
trouble qui est un trouble d'excès
c'est-à-dire c'est pas que j'arrive pas
à me reconnaître j'aimerais qu'on est
simultanément dans deux corps en fait
c'est comme si j'arrivais à dire c'est
moi deux fois et si on est si on y pense
c'est comment dire capacité de se
reconnaître de n'importe quelle forme du
monde c'est quelque chose qui nous
arrive très très souvent l'acte d'amour
c'est aussi quelque chose de ce type là
même s'il y a aussi au même moment une
force qui nous repousse
mais faire l'expérience de la gemmalité
c'est ça c'est avoir un face de toi
quelqu'un qui a ta même force et donc ne
pas savoir si c'est toi qui a copié
l'autre les mondes ou si c'est les
mondes qui t'a copié et c'est étrange
rapport de de presque de mimétique où on
sait pas qui a commencé à copier l'autre
c'est aussi quelque chose qui nous
traversons tous les temps penser c'est
faire cette expérience au fond penser
c'est se mettre dans un rapport mental
de gémellité au monde c'est de dire là
je suis en train de voilà de de dire
dénommer quelque chose et de faire des
sortes que je sais pas si c'est les
menthe qui a copié ma parole ou
l'inverse mais aussi percevoir c'est
quelque chose de ce type là la
gemmélitisme ce n'est pas quelque chose
de d'exceptionnel c'est juste le le
fait que notre rapport aux autres
devient ou prennent les mêmes femmes que
notre rapport au monde a de manière
quotidienne donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
écrit ou que je que j'ai dit que font
c'est une expérience beaucoup plus
universelle de ce que l'on imagine et
c'est pour ça peut-être qu'il faudrait
reconnaître la radicalité la
l'universalité de cette expérience parce
que reconnaître que tous et toutes sont
nos jumelles et nos jumeaux nous
permettrait par exemple de dépasser des
questions qui peut-être aujourd'hui nous
bloque excessivement qu'ils sont la
question de l'identité la question par
exemple de l'appartenance à une nation
ou à l'autre
etc au fond on est tous et toutes à mon
avis des jumelles et des jumeaux qui
habitent une seule planète c'est-à-dire
et ça c'est peut-être la prise des
consciences la plus nécessaire vu qu'on
parle de crise climatique
chacun et chacune de nous est une
littéralement jumelle et un Gémeaux des
Gaïa font en y réfléchit pas mais nous
sommes faits de la même chair que la
planète nous sommes la planète elle-même
qui à nous a décidé d'avoir une autre à
notre visage et de se regarder elle-même
avec des yeux un peu différents et c'est
à partir peut-être de ce de cette
reconnaissance qu'on pourra fonder
différemment l'écologie et inventer un
nouveau rapport au monde je vais vous
poser quelques questions un peu du tac
au tac quel est le rôle du philosophe
dans la cité est-ce qu'il est roi
hermite ou conseiller du prince
il est surtout artiste en fait il doit
tout d'abord inventer des rapports de
liberté dans les corps à corps avec la
matière du monde un grand artiste une
grande artiste c'est ça c'est quelqu'un
qui m'aime à manipulant de du marbre
arrive à exprimer sa propre liberté et à
faire de cette liberté exprimée les
fondements de la liberté des autres en
fait donc
et surtout les grands artistes
inventent et nous ouvrons vie qui
n'étaient pas imaginable auparavant donc
s'il y a une tâche publique du
philosophe c'est ça les trois livres de
philosophie qui vous ont construit
alors l'Éthique de Spinoza et vu que je
dis tout ce que je dis avant je dirais
que les oeuvres à philosophiques
et qui m'est Marc bon ça change souvent
parce que je continue à lire à étudier
donc il n'y a pas quelque chose du passé
c'est tous les trois mois que c'est
complètement bouleversé par par quelque
chose et je dis si je dois ajouter deux
oeuvres qui me marque en ces mamans
c'est sont la collection saiba de 2018
d'alessand calaison Mikel a des dessiner
pour Gucci qui était l'une des œuvres
philosophique les plus intéressantes
et une œuvre de Philippe parrainant qui
s'appelle anywen qui est une étrange
œuvre où l'oeuvre se présente comme un
personnage de fiction face à l'artiste
en fait un livre de littérature
les boutiques
quenelles de Bruno Schulz
le rôle de la transmission
les rôles de la transmission
donc on vit dans un monde qui ou tout
peut être transmis immédiatement et tout
existe en tant qu'il est capable de
circuler en fait les réseaux sociaux
sont ça donc je crois que on
ne doit pas se soucier de la
transmission d'ailleurs les gros
problèmes de l'université c'est que elle
n'a pas compris que la transmission se
fait ailleurs et qu'il y a de formes de
transmission qu'il a dépassent
énormément ce qui est important
aujourd'hui c'est retrouver les rôles de
l'invention et de l'imagination je crois
qu'on est dans ce Christ climatique mais
aussi une crise de l'imagination on a du
mal à imaginer les présents et surtout
les futurs on est comme castrer on a une
peur monstrueuse d'imaginer une future
possible donc il faut surtout revenir à
l'imagination plus que à la transmission
la transmission se fait de manière
mécanique et des manières industrielle
donc il faut surtout pas se soucier de
la façon dont les les savoirs sont
transmis et et voilà et peuvent circuler
aujourd'hui quelle est la grande
question philosophique
mais justement inventer des nouvelles
questions philosophique on vit dans un
monde qui n'est plus le même de nos
parents d'une grands-parents on est tous
et toutes des ados EDF donc la grosse
question c'est se dire se poser de
nouvelles questions c'est-à-dire
qu'est-ce que c'est la réalité qu'on a
en face de nos yeux parce que on n'a pas
les mots on n'a pas les mots on n'a pas
les concepts on n'a pas l'expérience de
ce monde donc il faut CGT se faire mal
c'est plus chez les genoux et essayer de
comprendre tout ce qui nous arrive merci
Emmanuel kucia merci à vous